สวัสดีค่ะครูปุ๊ก
สวัสดีค่ะครูบี
สวัสดี
ค่ะทุกๆคนค่ะขอต้อนรับทุกคนนะคะเข้าสู่
ห้องเรียน competer ไทยค่ะ
นะคะห้องเรียนภาษาไทยแบบธรรมชาติธรรมชาติ
ค่ะ
แปลว่าครูปุ๊กอ่ะก็สวยทำไมชาติครูบีก็สวย
ธรรมชาติแล้วก็พูดภาษาไทยแบบธรรมชาติด้วย
ใช่ค่ะเพราะว่าครูปุ๊กเนี่ยไม่ไปคลินิก
ค่ะจมูกก็จมูกโรยไม่มีซิลิโคนเป็นจำนวน
ธรรมชาตินะคะอ้าวแล้วถ้าเราพูดแบบไม่
ธรรมชาติล่ะคะ
[เพลง]
สบายดีไหมคะ
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
หรือว่าเหมือนเสียงของ Siri ใน Google
อะไรอย่างนี้
ก็ดีใจค่ะเพราะว่าวันนี้เนี่ยได้มาเจอครู
ปุ๊กนะคะ
เมื่อกี้เราก็มาเจอกันนะในวันจันทร์ค่ะ
วันนี้เนี่ยวันจันทร์ค่ะวันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
ครูบีวันที่ 28 ค่ะ
เพื่อนอะไรคะเดือนสิงหาคมค่ะเดือนสิงหาคม
เป็นเดือนที่เท่าไหร่คะ
เป็นเดือนที่ 8 ค่ะครูปุ๊กค่ะ
แล้วก็ปีคิดทศศักราชที่เท่าไหร่คะ
2,023 นะคะหรือว่า 200 อ่ะ 2023 อืมใช่
ค่ะนะวันนี้ก็ดูปุ๊บครูบีเนี่ยมาพบกับนัก
เรียนทุกๆคนนะคะในวันจันทร์วันที่ 28 นะ
เดือนสิงหาคมเป็นเดือนที่ 8 นะคะค่ะนะปี
พุทธศักราชหรือว่าพ.ศเนาะ
2506 ปีคิดถ้าศักราช
2023 ค่ะ
อ่า
นะโอ้โห
อ่ะขอดูเสื้อครูปุ๊บหน่อยค่ะ
นี่ค่ะเสื้อรูปุ๊บ
เนี่ยวันจันทร์
ไม่ต้องถอดค่ะครูบีแค่เห็นครูปุ๊กเนี่ย
ใส่เสื้อตรงกับวัน
เพราะว่าวันจันทร์เนี่ยคนไทยก็จะใส่สี
เหลืองใช่ไหมแต่ครูบีเนี่ยเสื้อเนี่ยเป็น
เมื่อวานค่ะครูปุ๊กอ๋อไม่ใช่ครูบีอยู่
อเมริกาใช่ไหม
ไม่ใช่ค่ะ
ไม่อาบน้ำใช่ไหม
อาบสิคะผู้หญิงสวยเนี่ยก็ต้องอาบน้ำจะได้
ไม่เหม็นค่ะ
[เพลง]
ใช่ค่ะสวยแต่เหม็นเนี่ยไม่โอเคค่ะแต่แปล
ว่าครูปุ๊กพูดว่าครูบีอยู่อเมริกา
เนี่ย
วันนี้เป็นวันอาทิตย์หรอคะ
ใช่ค่ะเพราะว่าอเมริกาเนี่ยช้ากว่าเราค่ะ
แต่ไม่ต้องถามนะคะว่ากี่ชั่วโมงเพราะว่า
อเมริกาเนี่ยใหญ่แล้วเขาก็แบ่งเป็น
ชั่วโมงที่ไม่ตรงกัน
แต่เราก็คิดว่าอเมริกากับไทยก็ไม่เหมือน
กันอยู่แล้วเนาะช้ากว่าประเทศไทยประเทศ
ไทยวันนี้เนี่ยเป็นวันจันทร์อเมริกาเป็น
วันอาทิตย์นะ
ประเทศไทยเป็นกลางวัน
อเมริกาเนี่ยเป็นการคืนนะนี่กลางวันก็จะ
มีแสงอาทิตย์ใช่ไหม
กลางคืนก็มีพระจันทร์พระจันทร์แล้วก็มี
ดาวดาว
[เพลง]
ประเทศไทยเนี่ยกลางวันประเทศอเมริกาก็จะ
เป็นกลางคืน
ทำไมเราพูดถึงอเมริกาครูปุ๊กเนี่ยจะพาครู
บีเดินทางไปเที่ยวอเมริกาเหรอคะ
ไม่ค่ะ
ไม่มีเงินค่ะ
ตอนนี้ดอลลาร์ขึ้น
ไม่เป็นไรงั้นเราก็เดินทางในประเทศไทยก็
ได้ค่ะประเทศไทยเนี่ยก็มีตั้ง 77 จังหวัด
อื้มโห
รูบี้ครูปุ๊กนะ
เบื่อไม่อยากเดินทางเลยค่ะ
อ้าวทำไมอ่ะคะอย่างครูปุ๊กตอนนี้อยู่
กรุงเทพฯใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่ะ
แล้วครูปุ๊กก็ไม่ใช่คนกรุงเทพฯเป็นคน
จังหวัดชลบุรีครูปุ๊กไม่อยากเดินทางไป
จังหวัดชลบุรีหรอคะพ่อ
แม่ค่ะเพราะว่าครูปุ๊กเนี่ยอยู่ชลบุรีก็
ตอนนี้เนี่ยไม่ได้อยู่ชลบุรีนานแล้วค่ะ
นะแล้วก็มีแต่บ้านของคุณพ่อคุณแม่ใช่ไหม
ที่ชลบุรี
ตอนนี้เนี่ยคุณพ่อคุณแม่ไม่อยู่แล้ว
แต่ว่า
ไม่ชอบเดินทาง
ใช่ค่ะ
นะประเทศไทยมี 77 จังหวัดใช่ไหมคะ
นะก็บ้านปลูกปุ๊บเนี่ยอยู่ชลบุรีค่ะ
อืม
นะสีส้มเนาะเอาเมาส์ชี้นะจังหวัดชลบุรี
ใช่
ครูครูบอกว่าไม่ชอบเดินทางเบื่อเวลาเดิน
ทางทำไมอ่ะคะ
เคยเกิดอะไรขึ้นน่ะครูปุ๊กทำไมไม่ชอบอ๋อ
ก็ตอนนี้เนี่ยครูปุ๊กเนี่ยไม่ได้อยู่บ้าน
ที่ชลบุรีใช่ไหมครูปุ๊ปก็ไม่อยู่ที่
กรุงเทพฯนี่กรุงเทพฯอยู่ตรงนี้นะคะ
ทีนี้เนี่ยครูปุ๊กเนี่ย
เมื่อก่อนก็จะไปหาคุณพ่อคุณแม่ที่บ้าน
ชลบุรี
แต่ว่าคุณพ่อเนี่ยตอน
เมื่อปี 62 นะ
ก็คุณพ่อเนี่ยไม่สบายแล้วก็คุณพ่อเขามี
บ้านอีกที่นึง
นะคะที่จังหวัดจันทบุรี
[เพลง]
จังหวัดนี้เลย
แล้วพอคุณพ่อไม่สบายเนี่ย
ครูปุ๊กเนี่ยต้องนั่งรถจากกรุงเทพฯแล้วก็
ผ่านฉะเชิงเทราชลบุรี
นะระยองจันทบุรี
นั่งรถเนี่ย
เบื่อค่ะ
แล้ว
จะเดินทางไปที่จังหวัดจันทบุรีใช่ไหมไปหา
คุณพ่อไปเยี่ยมพ่อเวลาคุณพ่อไม่สบายเนี่ย
ครูปุ๊กเดินทางยังไงคะขับรถไปหรอคะ
ขับรถไม่เป็นค่ะ
อ้าวครูปุ๊กขับรถไม่เป็น
แล้วครูปุ๊กจะไปยังไงคะ
ก็เป็นรถโดยสารสิคะรถโดยสารแบบเขาเรียก
ว่าสาธารณะเพราะว่า
ถ้าเป็นสาธารณะก็คือทุกคนเนี่ยมาใช้
บริการได้ค่ะนะมีเงินจ่ายเงินนะแล้วก็
ซื้อมันจะมีตั๋วให้นะสำหรับขึ้นรถไม่ฟรี
นะต้องจ่ายเงิน
เป็นรถโดยสารสาธารณะเนี่ยส่วนมากเราก็จะ
ใช้เนาะเวลาอยู่กรุงเทพฯแล้วก็ไปต่าง
จังหวัดนะแต่มันก็มีหลายๆแบบไง
เลือกใช้รถโดยสารแบบสาธารณะเนี่ยคือใช้รถ
อะไรเวลาจะไปคืออย่างนี้ถ้าครูปุ๊กคิดจะ
ไปอย่างตอนที่ครูปุ๊กบอกว่าปกติเนี่ยก็
คือถ้าไป
ทางภาคตะวันออกนะของประเทศไทยเนี่ยก็คือ
ชลบุรีระยองจันทบุรีตราดอะไรอย่างนี้ค่ะ
นะไม่ว่าจะเป็นปราจีนบุรีสระแก้วอยู่ใกล้
ๆกันนะคะนะก็อันนี้ก็จะเป็นภาคตะวันออกนะ
คะเราก็จะไปสถานีขนส่งภาคตะวันออกนะที่
ท่านนักเรียนอยู่แถวๆที่มี BTS ไปถึงก็
คือสถานีเอกมัยค่ะ
นะก็จะมีสถานี
เนี่ยค่ะสถานีขนส่งผู้โดยสารนะฮะ
ครูเทพ
เอกมัยอ้า
นี่คือถ้าจะไปภาคตะวันออกใช่ไหมก็ไปที่
สถานีนี้เนาะถูกต้องค่ะนะแล้วพอไปสถานี
นี้เนี่ยนักเรียนก็ไป BTS ได้นะคะเดินทาง
สะดวกเพราะว่านั่ง BTS ไปลงเอกมัยเราก็จะ
มองเห็นสถานีขนส่งเอกมัยเลยค่ะ
แล้วก็เดินไปค่ะเข้าไปข้างในค่ะ
นะ
เขาก็จะมีที่ที่ขายตั๋วโดยสารนะเขาจะมี
ที่ขายตั๋วอยู่ตรงนี้นี่เห็นไหม
อ่านภาษาไทยภาษาอังกฤษได้ก็มีอันนี้เข้า
ใจใช่ไหมมีรถไปที่ไหนบ้างนะอันนี้ก็จะ
เป็นรถตู้
รถตู้โดยสารเนอะ
ก็เราก็เป็นเรื่องค่ะว่าเราจะไปที่ไหน
แล้วก็ซื้อตั๋ว
นะเป็นช่องใช่มั้ยมีทั้งภาษาอังกฤษแล้วก็
ภาษาไทยนะคะแต่ถ้าเราไม่เข้าใจภาษาไทยเรา
ก็พูดได้ค่ะ
ชลบุรี
อ้าวไม่ใช่ชลบุรีเออไปชนแค่บอกจังหวัด
เนี่ยก็เข้าใจแล้วแหละเนาะอ่าครูบีแต่
อย่างนี้นะเพราะว่าบางทีอ่ะนักเรียนอยาก
ไปพัทยา
ก็อยู่ชลบุรี
แต่ว่ามันไกลจากตัวชลบุรีตัวเมือง
มันจะต้องเดินทางไปแบบไกลกว่านะจาก
กรุงเทพฯชลบุรีก็ประมาณ 60 กิโลเมตร
แต่ถ้าจากชลบุรีไปพัทยาอีกก็ประมาณอีก 70
นะออกไม่ใช่ 70 ด้วยเพราะว่ากรุงเทพฯ
ไปพัทยาเนี่ยประมาณ 150 กิโลเมตรเพราะ
ฉะนั้น 90 กิโลเมตร
แต่ว่าใช่บางทีเขาจะไม่บอกไงนักเรียนบอก
ว่าไปไปชลบุรีหรือไปพัทยาเนอะ
ไปไม่ถึงพัทยานะแล้วเขาก็บอกไปๆๆนะอืมแต่
พอขึ้นไปเนี่ยพอถึงชลบุรีเขาจะให้ลง
แล้วก็ให้เรียกรถคันใหม่
ซึ่งอันนี้ไม่ดีเลยไม่สะดวกด้วยนะไม่ดี
นักเรียนต้องซื้อตั๋วถ้ารู้ว่าจะไปลง
พัทยาก็ต้องซื้อพัทยา
ซื้อตั๋วเป็นของพัทยา
นะดีกว่าใช่ไหมคะแบบนี้ดีกว่าใช่ถ้าไป
บางแสนนักเรียนก็ซื้อตั๋วมันจะมีรถไป
บางแสนเลยจะเข้าไปที่ทะเลบางแสนด้วยนะ
แล้วก็ก็เลยเลือกซื้อที่นักเรียนไปหรือ
ว่าทุกคนจะไปตรงไหนก็ซื้อตรงนั้นเนาะเขา
ก็บางทีเขาไม่บอกไงแล้วเขาก็เหมือนจะโกหก
ไหมเขาไปๆแต่ว่าไม่ได้ไปจริงๆไปไม่ถึง
นะเราก็ต้องเสียเงินซื้อตั๋วแต่ไปไม่ถึง
แล้วก็ต้องไปต่อรถอีกใช่ไหมเปลี่ยนรถก็
ไม่โอเคไงใช่เพราะว่าเวลาเปลี่ยนรถเนี่ย
เก้าอี้ที่นั่งเนี่ยมันอาจจะไม่ดีเท่า
ไหร่ไง
บางทีต้องไปนั่งข้างหลังนู้น
ก็เลยแบบ
Book เนี่ยคือแบบเวลาจะไปที่ชลบุรีเนี่ย
ก็ไปที่สถานีขนส่ง
อ่าเอกมัยอือใช่ค่ะ
แต่ที่ครูปุ๊กๆเนี่ยเคยเจอประสบการณ์ที่
ไม่ดีเลยนะฮะรู้สึกไม่ชอบเลย
นะครูบีเพราะว่าตอนนั้นเนี่ยครูปุ๊กเนี่ย
ไปต้องไปหาคุณพ่อไม่สบายใช่ไหม
ไม่สบายแล้วก็เขามีบ้านอยู่จันทบุรี
แล้วเขาก็เลยไปนอนที่โรงพยาบาลจันทบุรี
ปีนี้เนี่ยครูปุ๊กอยู่กรุงเทพฯเนี่ยก็
ต้องไปหาคุณพ่อที่จันทบุรี
จะต้องนั่งรถโดยสารไปเนี่ยจากเอกมัยเนี่ย
ประมาณสัก 4 ชั่วโมง
ถึง 4 ชั่วโมงครึ่งแล้วแต่เนาะ
มันก็ไกลอยู่นะเพราะว่ารถโดยสารเนี่ยเขา
จะจอดไง
บางทีเขามีเบรกเข้าห้องน้ำ
เด็กกินข้าวอะไรอย่างนี้นะตอนเช้า
ครูปุ๊กก็
ไปแล้วก็นั่งคือถ้ารถใหญ่อ่ะนะมันแบบ
นักเรียนเข้าใจไหมมันช้ารถจะช้ากว่าเนี่ย
ค่ะรถแบบเนี้ยรถใหญ่รถบัสนะแต่เขาจะมีรถ
ตู้หรือว่าเป็นเหมือนมินิบัส
จะเล็กกว่าอันนี้ก็ไม่ต้องรอนานคนน้อย
กว่า
แล้วเขาจะวิ่งเป็นถนนที่เป็น
บางทีเป็นมอเตอร์เวย์ค่ะ
วิ่งยาวไปเลย
นะเพราะว่าคนเป็น
รถรถทัวร์หรือรถบัสแบบนี้ส่วนมากก็คือ
เขาจะต้องมีเวลาเบรคเวลาพักไงครูปุ๊กบาง
ทีเขาจอดที่สถานีอย่างนี้ใช่ไหมคะ
รถตู้ก็มีเหมือนกันค่ะถ้าวิ่งยาวๆ 4
ชั่วโมงอย่างนี้เขาจะเบรกแบบหนึ่งครั้งก็
คืออาจจะแบบสัก 2 ชั่วโมงหรือว่าชั่วโมง
ครึ่งเขาก็จะเบรกครั้งนึงแล้วก็วิ่งยาวไป
แต่ว่าที่นี้เนี่ยคือรถใหญ่ไงมันก็จะช้า
แล้วก็ต้องรอคนให้เต็มก่อนนะรอที่สถานี
เนี่ยกว่าจะไปเนี่ยกว่าจะออกเนี่ยนะเขาก็
ต้องรอคนนะแล้วก็ถ้าคนน้อยเราก็ต้องรอนาน
นิดนึงเขาก็จะยื่นระยะเวลาไปหน่อยนะฮะ
แล้วก็ถ้าเป็นรถเอ่อมินิบัสเนี่ยรถเอ่อรถ
บ้านเล็กๆเนี่ยคล้ายๆรถแวนค่ะมันจะใหญ่
กว่ารถแบรนด์นิดนึงเนี่ยนะมันก็นั่งสบาย
นะแต่ว่าคนไม่ได้เยอะเหมือนรถใหญ่
ครูปุ๊กก็ไปก็เลยเลือกนั่งแบบนี้ค่ะ
มินิบัส
ไปหาคุณพ่อเพราะว่าก็ราคาค่ารถเนี่ยก็
ประมาณสัก 300 บาท
เพราะว่าเขาจะวิ่งไปทางมอเตอร์เวย์ซึ่ง
มันไม่มันจะไม่มีไฟเขียวไฟแดงอะไรแบบนั้น
นะก็จะสะดวก
แล้วก็ครูก็เลยเลือกซื้อแต่ว่ามีอยู่วัน
นึงค่ะ
ก็คือปุ๊กเนี่ยไปถึงก่อนเลยค่ะ
คือปุ๊กก็จะเลือกที่นั่ง
ไม่รู้ว่าครูบีเนี่ยเคยนั่งไหมอ๋อ
ถ้าเป็นรถมินิบัสเหมือนครูปุ๊กให้ดูในรูป
หรอคะ
ครูบีเนี่ยไม่นั่งเลยค่ะแต่ถ้าเป็นรถตู้
เนี่ยครูบีเคยนั่งค่ะ
มันจะคล้ายๆกับรถตู้ค่ะรถตู้ก็คือรถ
แวนเนาะแล้วก็อันนี้มันจะใหญ่กว่ารถตู้
หน่อยนึงนะคล้ายๆแบบนี้ค่ะ
นี่เลยนะข้างในเนี่ยมันก็จะมีที่นั่งแบบ
นี้ค่ะ
ที่คุณปุ้มนั่งไปเนี่ยส่วนมากแล้ว
เดินทางคนเดียว
ครูก็จะไปนั่งข้างหลังนะก็ประมาณตอนนี้
ค่ะ
จะชอบนั่งตัวนี้เพราะว่าให้นั่ง 2 ตัวนี้
เขาก็จะเดินผ่านไปผ่านมาผ่านไปผ่านมาเนาะ
เราก็ไปตรงนี้ดีกว่า
คนที่ผ่านปุ๊กก็มีข้างหลังเท่านั้น
ใช่ไหมข้างหลังเนี่ยมีเก้าอี้ 4 ที่นั่ง
เห็นไหมคะ
1  2  3  4 เห็นไหมแต่ครูปุ๊กเนี่ยนั่ง
เก้าอี้เดี่ยวก็คือนั่งคนเดียวอ่าเห็นไหม
เพราะว่าขึ้นมาคนที่ 1 คนแรกก็เป็นนั่ง
เลยค่ะ
สบายๆแล้วก็รอรอเวลารอคนอื่นขึ้น
แล้วก็มีคนขึ้นมาเยอะเลยแล้วก็เต็มค่ะ
โดยที่ข้างหลังเนี่ยตรงที่ข้างๆรูปุ๊บ
เนาะก็จะเป็น
เป็น
อะไรคะ
ครูก็จะเรียกอะไรอ่ะจะเป็นอะไรอ่ะเป็นผู้
ชายไหมเขาก็ไม่ใช่ผู้ชายอ่ะค่ะ
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
เขาก็จะมีความเป็นผู้หญิงด้วยค่ะเหมือน
เขาก็จะ
คือมากัน 4 คนเนี่ยนะเป็นผู้ชาย 1 คนไม่
ใช่ผู้ชายผู้ชายที่เป็นกระเทยเราเรียก
กระเทยได้เนาะนะก็คือเป็นผู้ชายแต่ว่าเขา
เนี่ยจะชอบความเป็นผู้หญิง
แล้วก็มี
เราพูดง่ายๆก็คือเป็นกระเทยเป็นสาวประเภท
สองก็คือผู้ชายแต่ใจเนี่ยอยากเป็นผู้หญิง
อาจจะยังไม่ไปคีรีนิกใช่ไหมใช่การแต่งตัว
เป็นผู้ชายอยู่แต่เวลาพูดเนี่ยเราเข้าใจ
เนาะก็เป็นกระเทยใช่มั้ย 1 คน 2 คนค่ะนะ
คนแล้วก็มีผู้หญิงอีก 2 คนอ่ะก็เป็น 4 คน
เนาะใช่ค่ะเขาก็จะนั่งก็มีแบบผู้หญิง
เนี่ยจะนั่งข้างในนะทั้งสองเก้าอี้ใช่
มั้ยข้างหลังนึงแล้วก็ตรงข้างแถวเดียวกับ
ครูปุ๊บอ่ะก็เป็นผู้หญิงแล้วก็กระเทย
กระเทย
เนี่ยก็ตอนนั้นเนี่ยก็เป็น
เอ่อเป็นผู้ชายนั่งเป็นผู้ชาย 1 ผู้หญิง 1
แล้วก็ครูปุ๊ก
แล้วพอนั่งไปอ่ะคือเขาเป็นเพื่อนกันเนาะ
คือสองคนข้างหลังก็ไม่มีปัญหาเนอะเขาเป็น
อาจจะเป็นแฟนกันเขาก็ไม่ได้เสียงดังอะไร
คนอื่นก็เงียบๆแต่ว่ามี 4 คนนี้ที่เสียง
ดัง
[เพลง]
เพราะว่าเวลาที่เราจะเดินทางแล้วก็ใช้
เวลา 4 ชั่วโมง 5 ชั่วโมงบางจังหวัดเนี่ย
6 ชั่วโมง 8 ชั่วโมงใช่ไหม
เราก็อยากจะนั่งรถแล้วแบบสบายๆบางทีเรา
อาจจะหลับก็ได้เนาะกุ๊กๆใช่ค่ะแล้วก็อยาก
จะใช้เวลาตรงนั้นในการพักผ่อนเนอะก็อยาก
อยู่เงียบๆแล้วก็แบบอาจจะแบบคือครูปุ๊ก
อ่ะลืมด้วยลืมเอาหูฟังไป
ก็เลยไม่มีหูฟังก็เลยไม่ได้ฟังเพลงไม่ได้
ดู YouTube เพราะว่าถ้าเราเปิดโทรศัพท์
ใช่ไหมแล้วดู YouTube เนี่ยเราก็ต้องเปิด
เสียงไงเพราะไม่มีหูฟังใช่ไหมก็มันก็เกรง
ใจคนอื่นนะเขาอยากนอนเขาอยากอะไรจะมาได้
ยินเสียงเราดูหนัง
ไม่ได้นะคะถ้าครูปุ๊บนั่งรถโดยสารรถ
มินิบัสรถทัวร์รถตู้เนี่ยแบบสาธารณะเนี่ย
แล้วกูปุ๊บมาเปิดโทรศัพท์ดู YouTube
เนี่ยโห่กูบีบอกเลยคนที่นั่งใกล้ๆหรือคน
ที่อยู่บนรถเนี่ยเขาจะรำคาญครูปุ๊บมากๆ
ค่ะ
รู้สึกรำคาญมากเพราะว่าเสียงที่ครูปุ๊ก
เปิดเนี่ยมันทำให้คนอื่นเนี่ยโอ้โหไม่
สบายเนาะบางคนเขานอนอ้ามันรบกวนคนอื่นค่ะ
เขาจะรำคาญเอานะคะใช่เพราะว่าเขาไม่ได้ดู
กับเราไงนะได้ยินแต่เสียงบางทีมีเสียงปืน
ปุ้งปั้งปุ้งปั้งเขาก็จะแบบ
รำคาญรำคาญ
แต่ว่าครูปุ๊กเนี่ยก็รู้ไงว่า
มารยาทบนรถนะเราก็ไม่ควรเพราะว่ามันเป็น
รสสาธารณะไม่ใช่รถครูปุ๊บใช่ไหมก็เลยครู
ก็เลยไม่เปิดไงไม่ฟังกูก็นอนแต่ว่าคนที่
นั่งข้างๆใช่ไหมที่กูบอกว่านะแถวเดียวกับ
ครูปุ๊กมีกะเทยแล้วก็มีผู้หญิงแล้วก็มี
ผู้หญิงแล้วก็กระเทยเนี่ยเค้านั่งแล้วเขา
ก็คุยกันเสียงดังอ่ะ
เพราะว่าเขาคุยไปข้างหลังด้วยไง
อ๋อต้องคุยกับเพื่อนด้วยเอ้อว่าไง
โอ้โหสนุกมากเลยเรื่องเมื่อคืนเนี่ยอ่า
ใช่แล้วก็พูดไม่เพราะ
พูดเนี่ยภาษาเนี่ยไม่ดี
อ๋อพูดแบบภาษาไม่สุภาพใช่ไหมคะเออครูก็
ไม่อยากฟังเนาะแต่ทำยังไงได้ล่ะหูฟังก็
ไม่ได้เอามาลืมใช่ไหมก็เลยแบบก็นั่งแล้ว
ก็อดทนไม่เป็นไรนะไม่เป็นไร
เพราะว่า
ครูปุ๊กรู้สึกรำคาญเสียงพูดใช่ไหมว่าพูด
เสียงดังแล้วก็พูดไม่สุภาพใช่ถ้าครูบี
อยากจะนอนแล้วมีคนพูดกันเนี่ยนะพูดเนี่ย
ไม่เหมือนคุยกันนะเหมือนทะเลาะกันน่ะ
นึกออกไหมแทนที่จะแบบเฮ้ยเมื่อวานเป็นยัง
ไง
ไปดูหนังเรื่องนั้นมาเป็นไงอะไรอย่างนี้
ไม่ใช่อันนี้
เฮ้ย
มึง
มึงเนี่ยขอโทษนะคะ
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
ใช่ฉันคิดว่าอย่างนั้น
อ่านี่น้ำเสียงจะแบบสิงห์ดังใช่ไหมเออ
แบบเฮ้ย
มึงไม่ได้กลับมากี่ปีแล้วเนี่ยอะไรอย่าง
เงี้ยแล้วแบบ
คือเราอ่ะจะนอนเราก็ได้ยินเสียงมันก็
เดี๋ยวก็เสียงดังขึ้นมาอีกเดี๋ยวก็ดัง
ขึ้นมาอีกดังเดี๋ยวก็ฮ่าๆๆๆ
นอนได้ไหมล่ะคะ
รำคาญค่ะไม่ชอบเลยค่ะเวลาอยู่บนรถแล้วไม่
ใช่รถส่วนตัวไงเป็นรถสาธารณะเนี่ยไม่ชอบ
คนที่แบบขึ้นไปบนรถแล้วพูดเสียงดังๆเพราะ
เราจะรู้สึกรำคาญมาก
แต่ถ้าเป็นรถของเราเองเราจะพูดเสียงดัง
เนี่ยไม่เป็นไร
นะแต่พอนั่งไปสักพักใหญ่ๆเนาะเขาก็จะไป
จอดกินข้าวค่ะอุปกรณ์ดีใจนะได้ลงไปเดิน
เล่นบ้างแล้วก็
ครึ่งชั่วโมงเขาให้กลับขึ้นมาแล้วก็กิน
ข้าวเสร็จแล้วใช่ไหม
นะ
น่าจะนอนได้แล้วเพราะว่ากินอิ่มแล้วก็คุย
กันมานานแล้ว
ปรากฏว่า
โอ้โหครูบีน่ะกว่าเดิมอีกค่ะ
อะไรคะ
คือมี 1 คนเนี่ย
เหมือนกินกินแล้วก็น่าจะมีหมูมีไก่หรือมี
อะไรติดฟันนะคะอยู่ที่ฟันแล้วก็พยายาม
ทำไมคะเสียงดังเหรอโอ้โหครูบีเวลาเขาดู
มันจะมีเสียงตลอด
มันเหมือนมันไม่ออกอ่ะ
[เพลง]
ได้ยินไหมได้ยินที่ครูปุ๊กทำเสียงไหมได้
ยินค่ะมันก็จะแบบนี้ตลอดทาง
น่าจะมีหมูมีไก่ติดที่ฟันนะ
ครูปุ๊กก็ยิ่งรำคาญมากกว่าเดิม
รำคาญไหมล่ะครูบีมีคนมาดู
แล้วเรารู้สึกแบบ
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
จินตนาการไง
4 คนเนี่ยคุยกันเสียงดังทำให้ทุกคนคิด
ว่าทุกคนที่อยู่บนรถน่ะรำคาญแต่ไม่พูดไง
แต่ครูปุ๊กไงใกล้ๆ 4 คนไง
ใช่มั้ย
1 พูดเสียงดังคุยกันเสียงดังแล้วก็พูดคำ
ไม่สุภาพ 2 กินเสร็จแล้วยังมีไก่มีหมูติด
ที่ฟันแล้วก็
โอ้โห
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
ไม่ใช่แค่รำคาญอย่างเดียวอันนี้ครู
อ๊วกด้วยใช่มั้ย
ก็เลยหันไปดูคนข้างหลังใช่ไหมผู้หญิงผู้
ชายแฟนกันน่ะก็โอเคนะอ๋อเขาเนี่ยมีหูฟัง
เห็นไหมครูปุ๊กต่อไปเนี่ย
พกหูฟังนะคะ
อ่าต้องใส่ไว้เลยค่ะหูฟัง
พูดไปเลยค่ะ
พี่จะนอน
ตายแล้วเมื่อไหร่มันจะ
มันจะถึงสักทีอะไรอย่างเงี้ยเมื่อไหร่จะ
ถึง
มันยังไม่ถึงค่ะเพราะว่า 4 ชั่วโมงใช่
มั้ยนักเรียน
นะเราก็แบบนั่งแล้วก็
เดี๋ยวสักพักนึงคนข้างๆครูกุ๊กแล้วมันมี
ทางเดินนักเรียนจำได้เนาะมีเก้าอี้เดียว
ใช่ไหมของครูปุ๊กแล้วข้างๆมันจะเป็นทาง
เดินแล้วก็มีกระเทยแล้วก็ผู้หญิงใช่ไหมนะ
คนข้างๆเนี่ย
นะ
ที่ตัดเล็บขึ้นมาค่ะครูบี
ที่ตัดเล็บใช่ค่ะ
ที่ตัดเล็บเล็บมือเล็บเท้าเขาก็นั่ง
ปาก
มันก็
แก๊ก
ๆๆๆ
เอาแล้วไปตัดเล็บบนรถมินิบัส
ใช่ค่ะ
ไม่โอเคเลยค่ะแล้วเวลาตัดเล็บเนี่ย
เขาตัดเล็บมือก็ไม่โอเคนะเล็บเท้าก็ไม่
โอเคเพราะว่าเวลาเราตัดเล็บมันจะมีเสียง
ดังแล้วมันแล้วเขา
ตัดบนรถสาธารณะน่ะมันต้องไปตัดที่บ้านค่ะ
สกปรกนะพอมันพอเขามีที่ตัดเล็บใช่มั้ย
แป๊กเล็บเนี่ยมันจะกระเด็นไปทั่วเลยนะ
นะแล้วแบบโอ้โหคุณแบบอะไรเนี่ยแล้ว
คือรู้สึกแบบ
กูปุ๊บแล้วถ้าขุดปุ๊บมีแก้วน้ำอยู่เนี่ย
ไม่ๆๆกูก็มีขวดน้ำค่ะมีฝาปิดฝาปิดนะคะพอ
ตัดเล็บมือเสร็จเขาก็มีตะไบใช่ไหมตะไบ
แล้วก็
โอ้โห
บนรถมินิมัส
ใช่แล้วก็
เป่าค่ะ
แต่ว่า
โชคดีว่าตอนนั้นน่ะมีช่วงยุคโควิดใช่ไหม
เรามีหน้ากากอนามัยค่ะ
ต้องรีบใส่เลยค่ะหน้ากากอนามัยครูปุ๊กใส่
ตั้งแต่แรกอยู่แล้วค่ะ
ก็เขาก็ตะไบเล็บเสร็จครูก็คิดไม่เป็นไรอด
ทน 10 นิ้ว 1  2  3  4  5  6  7  8  9  10
โอเคไม่เป็นไรเนาะอดทนอดทนไว้
แต่
อะไรคะยังไม่ทันไร
นะ
นักเรียน
ยกเท้าขึ้นมาค่ะ
แล้วก็ลงไปแล้วก็นั่งตัดเล็บเท้า
แบบนี้เลยหรอคะ
ยกนี่ค่ะฉันเข่าขึ้นมาเลยค่ะ
ตัดเล็บเท้า
ทำได้ด้วยหรอ
อันนี้คือเขาไม่
ไม่มีมารยาทแล้วก็ไม่ไม่เกรงใจคนที่นั่ง
อยู่บนรถเลยเพราะว่ามันไม่ใช่รถส่วนตัว
มันเป็นรถที่ทุกคนเนี่ยจ่ายเงินใช่ไหม
แล้วก็
รถสาธารณะที่สำคัญ
หน้ารำคาญเสียงก็ดังใช่
อะไรเนี่ยวันนี้เป็นวันอะไรของครูปุ๊ก
ทำไมมันเป็นวันที่น่ารำคาญเหลือเกินแบบ
รำคาญเสียงแก๊กๆใช่ไหมตัดเล็บมือแล้วยัง
ตัดเล็บคือถ้าตะไบเล็บเนี่ยมันไม่มีเสียง
เนาะยังโอเคนะไม่มีเสียงไม่รำคาญแต่ยัง
ตัดเล็บเท้าอีกอีก 10 เล็บใช่มั้ย
เล็บมือเนี่ย 10 เล็บเท้าอีก 10 เป็น 20
แล้วก็ได้ยินเสียง
รำคาญมากๆนะใช่แล้วยังเสียงดูด
โอเคครูบีเข้าใจครูปุ๊กแล้วค่ะว่าทำไมถึง
ไม่อยากนั่งรถแล้วก็เดินทางไกลๆเนอะบางที
เนี่ยคนที่มานั่งรถเดียวกันกับเราใช่ไหม
มินิบัสคันเดียวกันเนี่ยบางทีเราก็เจอคน
ดีเจอคนไม่ดีแล้วถ้าคุยกันเสียงดังก็ทำ
ให้เรารู้สึกรำคาญนะแต่เราจะไปคอมเพลนไป
พูดไม่ได้เนาะบางทีเดี๋ยวโดนต่อยนะคะมัน
ก็กลัวเนาะอืมต้องอดค่ะ
เหรอแล้วก็ต้องอดทนค่ะเพราะว่าคิดไม่เป็น
ไร 4 ชั่วโมง 4 ชั่วโมงนะอดทนไปอ่ะ
นะแต่ตลอดทางค่ะกูรู้สึกว่ารำคาญมากๆรู้
สึกโอ้โหคุยกันก็เสียงดัง
คุยภาษาก็ไม่สุภาพ
ตัดเล็บอีกก็มีเสียงอีกเออนะยังมีดู
ถ้าครูบีชวนครูปุ๊กไปไหนเนี่ย
เอ่อ
ถ้าเป็นรถส่วนตัวโอเคค่ะ
ครูบีก็ไม่ชอบนั่งรถสาธารณะเพราะว่าลำธาร
คนเสียงดังแบบนี้ล่ะค่ะเดี๋ยวถ้าครูปุ๊ก
อยากไปเที่ยวพัทยาชลบุรีครูปุ๊กมาค่ะ
เดี๋ยวครูบีเป็นคนขับรถครูปุ๊กเนี่ย VIP
เลยค่ะนะ
จ่ายค่าน้ำมันให้จ่ายค่ากินให้
ครูบีค่ะ
[เพลง]
ไม่เป็นไรค่ะเพราะว่าครูบีเนี่ย
ใส่หูฟัง
ไม่เป็นไรกลัวเสียงดังครูบีก็โอเคเพราะ
ว่าเป็นครูปุ๊กนะครับเป็นรถส่วนตัวอุ๊ย
แต่ว่าวันนี้เดี๋ยวเราต้องอ่าไปก่อนดี
กว่าครูปุ๊กก่อนที่นักเรียนจะรำคาญครูค่ะ
นักเรียนจะบอกว่าเอ๊ะทำไมครูพูดมากๆรู้
สึกรำคาญแต่ไม่เป็นไรนะถ้าครูพูดมากๆ
เนี่ยนักเรียนจะได้ฟังภาษาไทยมากขึ้นค่ะ
เดี๋ยววันนี้เราลานักเรียนไปก่อนดีกว่า
ค่ะได้ค่ะขอบคุณค่ะสวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะ
พบกันนะคะ